en esta ocasión vamos a usar varios
espejos parabólicos pues en este vídeo
quiero hacer varios ejemplos de objetos
que se encuentran enfrente de estos
espejos pensando en cuál sería la imagen
reflejada de estos objetos con base en
qué tan lejano se encuentran de los
espejos además de darnos un mejor
entendimiento de los espejos parabólicos
esto nos va a ayudar a comprender cómo
manipularlos y entender cómo se
comportan los rayos de luz que es algo
útil cuando tratamos de aprender sobre
otros tipos de dispositivos reflectores
o reflectores como son los lentes aquí
tengo dibujado un espejo parabólico que
tiene aquí su foco y acaso centro de
curvatura que recordemos que este centro
de curvatura va a estar al doble de
distancia que el punto focal
ya tengo copiada esta figura para
poderla usar más adelante sin tener que
estar dibujando todo lo que vamos a
hacer y que hicimos en el vídeo anterior
es poner un objeto frente al espejo y
aquí vamos a usar la convención de
indicar un objeto mediante una flecha
una flecha así y la punta de la flecha
indica en dónde termina el objeto esto
no es un rayo de luz es un objeto físico
que se encuentra aquí frente al espejo
también es muy común usar esta punta de
la flecha como punto de partida de los
rayos de luz aunque éstos pueden salir
desde cualquier otro punto del objeto al
tener espejos parabólicos lo más
sencillo es dibujar dos rayos uno que
sea paralelo al eje principal como éste
un rayo que sale de aquí de la punta y
es paralelo al eje principal
que al rebotar o al ser reflejado va a
cruzar el punto focal
y otro rayo de luz pero este sale del
mismo punto pero va a pasar por el foco
o menos así y al tocar el espejo va a
ser reflejado de manera paralela al eje
así este es el ejemplo que vimos en el
vídeo anterior y para cualquier rayo de
luz emitido a partir de este objeto
aquellos que sean paralelos al eje se
van a reflejar pasarán por el foco y los
que pasen por el foco se reflejarán y
serán paralelos por lo que van a
converger en este punto de acá en este
punto de acá puedo elegir un punto
intermedio de este objeto por ejemplo
este elijo un rayo que sale de forma
paralela al eje toca el espejo se
refleja pasa por el foco
de este mismo punto que va a pasar por
el foco se va a reflejar paralelamente
quedando en este punto y creo que con
esto es obvio que aquí se va a formar
una imagen
el objeto original esta será una imagen
de cabeza o invertida del objeto y será
una imagen real más pequeña que el
objeto verdadero y voy a mostrar esto
más claramente voy a pegar esta imagen
acá la voy a acomodar porque aquí voy a
dibujar el objeto pero de manera más
alejada y un poquito más grande pero
antes para no confundirnos voy a poner
que aquí en este caso está
esta es una imagen real imagen
es real porque si ponemos aquí una
pantalla vamos a tener una proyección
donde esta proyección va a difundir la
luz de la misma manera que lo hace el
objeto real
va a ser invertida una imagen real
invertida
y este objeto está más lejano que el
centro de curvatura no sólo va a ser una
imagen real invertida también va a ser
más pequeña
pequeña ahora sí vamos a hacer un poco
más claro este concepto dibujo aquí el
objeto alejado del punto focal un poco
más grande
punto y de aquí voy a tomar un rayo de
luz que va a ser paralelo
el eje principal aquí la luz va a
reflejarse pasando por el foco
más o menos así dibujo otro rayo de luz
que va a pasar por el punto focal
al pasar por el punto focal toca el
espejo y se refleja de manera paralela
al eje principal
aquí ya podemos ver que en la imagen
donde se intersectan estos puntos la
imagen va a quedar por acá nuestra
imagen real reflejada iba a estar
invertida y es más pequeña que la imagen
del objeto original ahora hagamos esto
de nuevo pero vamos a trabajar poniendo
el objeto en el centro de curvatura
vamos a poner nuestro objeto aquí
y hacemos lo mismo para este objeto aquí
recordamos que este es el eje principal
principal de la parábola
y también es la línea de simetría de
esta misma parábola
vamos a dibujar ambos rayos uno que sea
paralelo al eje
se refleja y pasa por el foco y otro
rayo sale del mismo punto pasa por el
foco y es reflejado de manera paralela a
nuestro eje y aunque mi dibujo no es el
mejor podemos ver que esta imagen
reflejada que voy a poner en un color
más clarito esta imagen reflejada es del
mismo tamaño que la imagen original así
que en este caso vamos a escribir aquí
tenemos una imagen real invertida y más
pequeña aquí está también vamos a tener
una imagen real imagen
también va a estar invertida
es del mismo tamaño
del mismo mismo
tamaño
hagamos un par de ejemplos más para
seguir familiarizándonos con estos
espejos parabólicos y también les puedo
recomendar que ustedes pausa en el vídeo
y tomen lápiz y papel y hagan esos
ejercicios ustedes mismos para que se
sigan familiarizando y comprendan mejor
estos conceptos pegamos nuestra imagen
la re acomodamos más o menos por acá y
ahora vamos a colocar nuestro objeto
entre el centro de curvatura y nuestro
punto focal nuevamente tomamos un rayo
que sale de aquí y va a ser paralelo
toca el espejo se refleja y pasa por el
punto focal y tenemos un rayo que sale
del mismo punto pasa por el punto focal
toca el espejo se refleja de manera
paralela al eje ahora que tenemos pues
que la imagen resultante va a hacer de
entrada va a ser más grande que la
imagen original y va a estar más alejada
de hecho es inverso a lo que hicimos en
este caso ahora regresamos a nuestra
posición original y vamos a notar que en
este caso obtenemos una imagen real
imagen real
y más grande y más grande
el objeto original la luz va a converger
en un punto más lejano que el centro de
curvatura ustedes se pueden imaginar que
si éste de abajo fuera un objeto esto de
aquí arriba sería su imagen simplemente
las líneas van en sentido contrario hay
una asimetría entre este ejemplo y el
que dibujamos más arriba vamos a hacer
un par de ejemplos más ahora nuestro
objeto nuestro objeto lo dejamos por acá
nuestro objeto de interés va a estar
justo en el punto focal va a estar
justamente acá
jugamos nuestro rayo paralelo que sale
acá
y he reflejado hacia el foco
y bueno en este caso no vamos a poder
dibujar un rayo de luz que pase por el
foco porque aquí es donde se encuentra
nuestro objeto aquí vamos a hacer algo
un poquito diferente aquí voy a dibujar
un rayo que intersecta al espejo
parabólico en el vértice en esta parte
de acá sabemos que en este punto esta
parte del espejo va a ser plana y
vertical por lo que podemos imaginar que
el rayo incidente tendrá el mismo ángulo
que el rayo reflejado así que dibujo mi
otro rayo de luz que va a este vértice
se va a reflejar exactamente con el
mismo ángulo
más o menos así entonces cuando tenemos
un objeto en el punto focal no vamos a
tener una imagen ya que toda la luz que
salga de este objeto se reflejará
paralelamente y no va a converger por lo
que no podrá formar una imagen real y
tampoco formará una imagen virtual ya
que estos rayos al extenderse hacia
afuera jamás se van a interceptar
por lo que aquí en este caso simple y
sencillamente no hay imagen
ahora nuestro último caso a analizar
ponemos nuestro dibujo lo colocamos aquí
y ahora como ustedes ya se podrán
imaginar lo que nos falta hacer es poner
el objeto mucho más cercano de lo que
está el punto focal aquí ahora dibujamos
el rayo de luz paralelo llega acá y se
va a reflejar
hacia el foco aunque este mismo objeto
va a impedir que el rayo de luz llegue
al alcance al foco y en el caso del rayo
que pasa por el foco no vamos a tener un
rayo de luz que emane hacia el punto
focal como lo hicimos en los elementos
anteriores lo que vamos a hacer es tomar
un rayo que tenga aparentemente la misma
dirección como si hubiera provenido de
este punto focal y al reflejarse aquí y
al llegar aquí se va a reflejar de esta
manera paralelamente estos dos radios no
van a converger a unirse en algún punto
pero dar la impresión como si viviera
o fueran emanados de algún punto detrás
del espejo si lo observaron a una
persona observándolo acá le daría la
impresión de que este radio de acá
continúa y este otro rayo continúa así
y hubiera una imagen o un reflejo
virtual de este objeto en esta parte de
acá vamos a ponerlo en el color del
objeto para que se note mejor
sería esta entonces una imagen virtual
no vamos a tener una proyección del
objeto pero sí va a dar la impresión de
que está el reflejo del objeto o que se
encuentra algo atrás del espejo y es más
grande que el objeto por lo que esto va
a actuar como una lente de aumento si
ustedes han ido alguna feria que tenga
una casa de los espejos verán que si se
acercan a un espejo parabólico ustedes
podrán ver una imagen virtual
amplificada de ustedes mismos así que en
este último ejemplo tenemos aquí una
imagen virtual imagen virtual
virtual más
para ilustrar lo que sucede aquí mejor
permíteme redibujar esto voy a hacer más
espacio para dibujar otro espejo
parabólico aquí más grande
con su eje principal
aquí su línea de simetría aquí va a
tener el punto focal
este es el punto focal y mi objeto se
encuentra más cercano a este punto focal
este es mi objeto
entonces tenemos un rayo que sale de
aquí de este punto va a ser paralelo
el eje principal va a rebotar en
dirección hacia el punto focal aunque no
va a llegar a este punto porque el mismo
objeto va a bloquear este rayo de luz y
para el otro rayo no tenemos un rayo de
luz que emana de aquí y pase por el
punto focal y sea reflejado por el
espejo en este caso lo que hacemos es
tomar un rayo de luz que dé la sensación
o que tenga la apariencia de venir de
este punto focal de manera que llega
aquí al espejo y va a ser reflejado de
manera paralela así
estos dos rayos divergen pero dan la
impresión de que provienen de un mismo
lugar si extendemos este rayo de luz acá
obviamente esto es algo que nuestros
cerebros hacen cuando hay un rayo de luz
van a inferir que viene de una línea
recta entonces al extender estos dos
rayos les va a dar la impresión de que
hay un reflejo de este objeto atrás del
espejo así y el tamaño del reflejo es
más grande que el objeto original y esta
será la imagen virtual de este objeto
espero que esto les haya ayudado a tomar
práctica y trabajar con este tipo de
espejos y se reconoce comportan estos
rayos de luz arbitrarios al ser
reflejados aquí aunque podemos
ejemplificar con puntos de luz en todo
el objeto es mucho más sencillo elegir
estos dos puntos porque ya sabemos cómo
se comportan los reflejos